hacia el Horizonte solo se ve un humo
espeso producto de casi 400.000
hectáreas carbonizadas desde que los
incendios forestales se iniciaron en
Canadá hace más de una semana lluvias
dispersas en los últimos dos días han
amortiguado las llamas pero el daño Ya
está hecho cheryl tenía un negocio de
alquiler de canoas aquí antes del
incendio no queda nada Ella se resigna a
lo poco que le queda
es difícil ver 16 años de trabajo
desaparecidos es difícil pero mi esposo
está vivo y salvo y mi mascota está
salvo mis hijos están a salvo todos
estamos a salvo eso es más importante
que lo material
la provincia canadiense de Alberta ha
informado de 24.000 evacuados Hasta el 9
de mayo se han llamado a refuerzos
militares para ayudar a combatir las
llamas en las autoridades dicen han
quemado 10 veces más la superficie En
comparación con años anteriores
lo que estamos tratando de hacer es
minimizar el crecimiento del fuego y
trabajar desde afuera fue una condición
extrema el viernes vimos estos Vientos
de 50 kilómetros por hora y en los
próximos días vamos a verlo cada vez más
seco y más duro Alberta ha declarado
estado de emergencia con más de 50
escuelas cerradas las autoridades
advierten que esto podría ser tan solo
el comienzo de una temporada de
incendios forestales a medida que el
clima se vuelve más cálido y seco debido
al calentamiento